thank you for that that's great that's
right
cuz was not an easy news week so let's
start with something positive how about
the Pope I love him again the Pug opened
a can of whoop-ass on greedy polluting
industrialist [ __ ]
he said climate changes really said we
are living in a structurally perverse
economic system where the rich exploit
the poor and it's turning the earth into
an immense pile of Filth and the
Republican response was swift and
immediate they said and what's your
point papi
go back to washing feet also second big
good piece of news the Treasury
announced that by the end of the decade
there's going to be a woman on the $10
bill we've never had a woman on paper
currency and as I thought it was going
to be Harriet Tubman the abolitionist
from the Civil War era but I found out
yes yesterday she's actually a white
girl from still can so it's not gonna
happen
oh I bought that Rachel Dolezal she
dominated the news for a while didn't
she
boy she was on today she on The Today
Show with Matt Lauer it's sticking to
her story she said she identifies as
black and Matt Lauer said yeah I
identify as someone with hair oh
speaking of people who dress up as black
women Obama was a Tyler Perry's House
today or was it yesterday he doesn't
okay
by the way president for the president
another tough week for him because this
was the 14th time he had to address the
nation on a mass shooting this one of
course you heard in South Carolina this
one an unapologetic white supremists it
is amazing how these white men who
believe they're a member of the master
race always look like the half-wit who
sprays fungicide in the shoes at the
bowling alley
and on fox news they could not decide if
this was absolutely not the right time
to talk about guns or absolutely not the
right time to talk about racism and yet
you know the shooter purposefully went
to a black church he told the victims
that he had to do it because they were
taking over he wore pro apartheid
stickers on his jacket his friend said
he was big into segregation he talked
about starting a race war so naturally
when it comes to what motivated him
Republicans are stumped there they
cannot figure it out that the governor
of South Carolina nikki Haley said will
never understand Jeb Bush we can't know
Jindal Lindsey Graham Tripp all of them
said it's some version of it's
incomprehensible there is just no way to
know what motivated a racist to kill
black people fellas you know what when a
guy like this talks about the South will
rise again
he's not talking about IQ levels
this guy this guy openly said he was
trying to start a race war which is
delusional because if Donald Trump
speech didn't do it the day before
nothing where did you see that oh my god
it's Donald Trump after three years
since the last election of every single
conservative in this country saying if
the Republicans ever hope to win the
White House back they have to reach out
to Latinos Donald Trump opens his
campaign saying Mexicans they bring
drugs they bring crime in they're
rapists
oh wait
I meant to say fraternities they're the
ones who know Trump said when Mexico
sends its people they're not sending
their best I love this idea that Mexico
is sending its people
hey you Rodriguez now there is Cabrera
get up here you're next come on in the
pipeline
obviously it's mean the white woman who
thinks she's black and drum thinking he
could be President it was a very good
week for nut cystic narcissistic person
helping him get to looker it's like
you're abnormal psych textbook came to
life and Donald Trump's speech was so
perfectly impeccably beautifully
unhinged and unfactored like he said
economic growth has never been below
zero until the last quarter it's been
below zero forty-two times since World
War two he said there are no jobs to be
had there are 5.4 million openings the
most in 15 years he said we've never
beaten Japan at anything money yeah he
was talking out of his ass so much
that's what point a roadie went onstage
and put a mic behind him
I love this he just rambled on like
Castro you know going on and on for
hours and then finally went I swear this
is his quote he said to sum up I would
do various things very quickly who is
not going to want to vote for that
ladies and gentlemen various things very
quickly
and there was a little scandal you know
with his announcement because it turned
out of some of these supporters who came
out to watch him were actually movie
extras who were paid fifty dollars I am
guessing this is not the first time
Donald Trump has paid someone fifty
dollars to pretend he excites them but
like they he has one real fan Sarah
Palin Sarah Palin took to her Facebook
page to say he's courageous tenacious
and he will fire up the economy
she may not convince a lot of voters but
you sure earned her fifty dollars
you